good morning Hank it's Wednesday yes
here we have Maureen in the tub awesome
in here you can see that it has Chloe
feet not her she doesn't I don't know
coffee well she's wearing boots we can't
know that actually that was Sunday night
I just wanted some proof that I had left
the little room that video was taken to
Cork Ireland where I went for a few days
after I finished the deadline and now
I'm back again but this is my last video
for vlogbrothers this is it since this
is my last day I thought I went to
finish up my little series on writing
and the publishing process since it's
the only thing I really know about many
of you have asked what's the general
process getting a book published of
taking that thing that you've worked on
at home and you've gone through your
period of suck and now you've made your
thing what do you do with it the thing
that you need after that point is
someone called an agent it's getting
late so I got to speed this up and cook
dinner while I make this video but very
quickly what's an agent an agent is
someone who represents you in the
publishing world there are a few people
who don't have agents but pretty much
everyone has an agent and the reason is
that editors usually don't read anything
unsolicited they only read things that
come from agents and your agent does
your contracts and they send up your
submissions and they basically take care
of all the business e stuff so you can
be creative it's in your house and write
and suck as much as you can
ha ha ha yeah very funny I said stuff
again the way you get an H initial write
in one page document called a query
letter as
flawless fascinating is eternally shot
and get their attention not gonna lie to
you getting agent is kind of hard and I
just wrote to my agent Nestor how hard
is it to get an agent and she said well
last year I got 3,500 query letters from
those 3,500 query letters I took the two
clients I realized that may seem very
daunting but I've always told you it's a
business and that's part of the whole I
don't think you should publish when
you're 15 years old thing because this
crap takes some adjusting to and you
have to have a arsenal of facts so that
you can deal with the business side of
it and also again you have to practice
writing for much much longer now there
are lots of people on the internet
giving you advice on how to write these
query letters and some of the people are
really really good some people have
absolutely no idea what they're talking
about because I don't know if you've
noticed this but sometimes there is
wrong stuff on the internet
personally the people I would listen to
when looking for advice on how to write
query letters would be agents but anyway
I asked my agent for a few general tips
on things you should or shouldn't do in
a query letter here are some of the
things she said don't have your
characters right the query letter for
you this will just make you seem crazy
don't put in recommendations from people
that they don't know 0 series of quotes
from people who read and love my book
and it's just some random people that
they don't know they're going to think
why who are these random people and why
do I care about their opinions it's
probably your grandmother
don't say that your book is going to
make a really big movie you're gonna
going to be the next Twilight or Harry
Potter or WIPA kid or what have you
feeling like here that's really
presumptuous and again it's not a
reality it's just something that you're
thinking which is great that you're
thinking that although you should try to
be yourself and not somebody else and
it's just going to make you seem
arrogant weird all they want is a good
clear letter about the story do follow
the instructions do write a really clean
letter dude check it a million billion
zillion times do make sure
has no mistakes in it make it the very
best thing that you have a bit on one
page that's it you me I'm done I'm done
I can't believe I ended it so quickly
like while cooking dinner but John
welcome back and I'll miss you guys come
and visit me and I guess I sign off Hank
I'll still be seeing you on Friday even
though I won't be